welcome back you know lebron james calls
the founding of his i promise school in
akron his
biggest accomplishment ever think about
the magnitude of that and there's a look
at some of the i promise school
students virtually coming to us and
watching this game today he's very
heavily invested in that school
very heavily invested in the success of
those students
through the years lebron has helped send
hundreds of kids to college and when you
talk about making an impact on your
community and beyond
he's living it he's doing it and they
are witness to it
rachel has more rachel yeah well guys i
was fortunate enough to be there with
lebron the day the i promise school
opened
it's beyond impressive not just in terms
of the education it's providing these
kids during school hours
but they have a full pantry to make sure
everyone has the healthy meals you need
to be able to learn and get through your
day
there's a ged program for students
parents who want to get their own
education improve their chances of jobs
the foundation even provides
transitional housing for students
families who find themselves in need
they call that the i promise village and
it has a communal family room
and that's where a lot of the kids and
teachers and parents that you're seeing
in the crowd here virtually are sitting
right now they're all watching together
mark and doris i would expect them to be
plenty loud and very enthusiastic
the lebron james family foundation a big
part of the success
of the i promise school
a lot of fans watching not just the i
promise school students but